this week's 48 Hours investigates the
mysterious death of an Alabama woman in
2017 Tiffany Crawford was found dead in
her van with a gun in her hand but when
investigators realized the gun was in
her non-dominant hand they became
suspicious of her husband our lead
National correspondent and 48 Hours
contributor David begno sat down with
the husband Jason Crawford for an
exclusive interview
it was the night of May 2nd 2017 when
37-year-old Jason Crawford called 9-1-1
from outside of his home in Coleman
Alabama
body camera footage shows what sheriff's
deputies found when they first arrived
on scene what happened tonight we were
arguing and last thing I remember I was
going in the house and I heard a shot
scream and then another shot
Jason's wife 32 year old Tiffany
Crawford was found dead in the driver's
seat of her own van there was a gun in
her left hand
to at least one of the deputies on the
scene it appeared as though it was a
suicide but once investigators dug
deeper that theory started to crumble
and Jason had some tough questions to
answer to believe that she did it to
herself you have to believe she used her
non-dominant hand very impulsive and
then shot herself twice yes
most suicides don't involve Two Shots
yes most not all
Dr Valerie Greene conducted Tiffany's
autopsy and ruled her death a homicide
she noticed something about that van in
which Tiffany was shot I remember
looking at pictures
of the driver's side door and I didn't
see any blood on that door that makes me
think that
the door was not closed and I think that
that door is open
because he was standing there
but Jason insists he is innocent did
anything about your relationship with
Tiffany lead you to believe that she was
suicidal not at the time looking back
just seeing how depressed she actually
was and reading some of her journal
makes me think she was hiding a lot of
stuff
David begno joins us now David good
morning so what made investigators
believe that it was Tiffany's husband
Jason who was responsible and not
someone else
well so he was at the scene that night
Vlad he called 9-1-1 and what is really
interesting one of the many things of
this hour that's very interesting is
that in the 9-1-1 phone call the
dispatcher asks Jason I want to say
three times maybe more who shot your
wife and every time she asks that
question there's no response from Jason
Crawford
hmm wow what did the forensic show
because he seems pretty uh adamant that
he didn't do it he's very calm when he's
talking to you
yeah so here's here's the deal Gail the
forensic showed that there was male DNA
on the gun but they couldn't say for
sure that it was Jason Crawford's it
appeared to some as though the gun had
been wiped possibly
wow anything that works in his favor
then David since he says I didn't do
this yeah at the end of the day there's
no direct physical evidence pointing to
Jason's Guild in fact Jason says Hey
listen Tiffany had some journal entries
on the day she died that said she was
struggling what to struggling with what
to do with herself right so he pointed
he and his defense team to those entries
saying that's proof that she was
thinking about taking her own life but
you are going to hear from a juror named
Megan who sat on that case and she is
going to tell you in the final moments
when they went to that jury room they
sat down and they looked at each other
and they said let's go back and listen
to that 9-1-1 call and watch the body
camera footage again and when they did
that something happened and there's a
moment she says that was it we all
decided boom
here's what we think all right that's
how they made their decision right it's
like to know what the jurors are
thinking yeah exactly what we're looking
forward to your report David thank you
very much you can see David's report the
mysterious death of Tiffany Crawford on
48 hours tomorrow night at 10 9 Central
right here on CBS and on Paramount plus
David is such a good storyteller